just like its name says NATO is a North
Atlantic organization here's the
Atlantic and all of these blue flags
represent NATO countries the whole
reason that the organization came
together in the first place was to
protect against possible threats from
the Soviet Union and it's now protecting
against Russia but lately NATO has been
ramping up Partnerships on the other
side of the world in the Pacific and
challenges from China are the big reason
why so how do NATO Partnerships work and
what do they mean for both NATO allies
and potential adversaries
just weeks before Russia launched its
full-scale invasion of Ukraine
presidents Xi Jinping and Vladimir Putin
held this Summit they released this
joint statement which made headlines
around the world they declared that the
friendship between the two states has no
limits and they said that the sides
oppose further enlargement of NATO and
call on the North Atlantic Alliance to
abandon its ideologized cold war
approaches Russia and China see NATO
expansion as a huge threat is
[Music]
but ever since Russia launched its
full-scale invasion of Ukraine just
weeks after that statement was put out
NATO has gotten both bigger and stronger
not only did Russia's neighbors Finland
and Sweden move to join the alliance but
some of the countries in China's
backyard moved to strengthen their
relationships with NATO too I'm talking
about the Pacific South Korea Japan New
Zealand and Australia while they aren't
taking full membership they worry that
what's happening in Ukraine could also
happen here in Taiwan the self-ruled
island that Beijing claims as part of
China and has threatened to take by
force Taiwan is Tiny But it produces a
majority of the world's Advanced
semiconductors those are the microchips
that power our Electronics our cars our
medical devices basically our whole
lives and a war over Taiwan could
devastate economies no matter where
they're located in the world and that's
why we keep hearing the NATO Secretary
General say this security is not
Regional Securities Global what happens
in the in the Pacific matters for Europe
for NATO and what happens in in Europe
matters for the indo-pacific for the
past two years leaders of the so-called
Asia Pacific 4 have attended major NATO
Summits and events and those countries
militaries have conducted exercises
alongside NATO these developments have
frustrated Beijing which says quote NATO
is intervening in Regional Affairs and
inciting block confrontation now NATO
maintains that it is a defensive
Alliance and according to its Chief we
will be remiss if we did not expose the
challenges that China poses to our
security to our values and to our
interests experts say those challenges
aren't just in Taiwan they're happening
all over the world like in Europe where
Chinese firms own stakes in ports roads
and Railways in Africa where the Chinese
have stakes in critical mining
operations and Technology infrastructure
in the Arctic where China is developing
gas projects and transportation
corridors and in space and cyberspace
where Beijing has been advancing its
military capability
last year for the first time NATO's
concerns about China appeared in its
main guiding document the Strategic
concept NATO says China is trying to
control key technology in industrial
sectors is using economic leverage to
create strategic dependencies and is
trying to subvert the rules-based
international order China says NATO's
concerns disregard facts and confuse
right and wrong but here's the thing not
every NATO member is on the same page
when it comes to how far the alliance
should go to counter China if a NATO
member like the U.S gets involved in a
war in the Pacific allies aren't
obligated to participate since Article 5
only considers an armed attack against
one or more allies in Europe or North
America as an attack against them all
plus different NATO countries have
varying levels of interconnectedness
with China so some are more hesitant
than others to ramp up pressure for
example NATO has discussed setting up a
liaison office in Tokyo but so far those
plans have been blocked by French
officials and president Emmanuel macron
says that enlarged NATO's spectrum and
geography would be a mistake with or
without physical offices experts say
that NATO and its Partners could benefit
from collaborating on things like cyber
security space security disinformation
and even climate change but when it
comes to a potential War over Taiwan
would NATO members and partners send Aid
like they have to Ukraine or perhaps get
more involved in the fight their
possible role remains a major question
and is something that the United States
is still trying to work out the defense
of freedom is not the work of a day or a
year
it's the calling of our lifetime
of all time